das ist jetzt wirklich nicht mehr lustig
die usa haben eine reisewarnung für
deutschland und belgien ausgegeben und
ich finde den grundriss schlimm eine
masern-epidemie hervorgerufen durch
impfgegner dabei ist mit dieser
krankheit überhaupt nicht zu starten in
berlin gab es bereits das erste opfer
denn mal was ist zwar eigentlich eine
harmlose kinderkrankheit doch immer
wieder sterben menschen das ist absolut
überflüssig unser thema jetzt praktisch
vom ganzen [ __ ] dazugekommen
leute leute leute da hat mal ein
englischer forscher in einer studie mit
einer sehr kleinen antrag untersuchter
kinder der masernimpfung die auslösung
von autismus unterstellt man kommt
danach heraus dass er massiv manipuliert
hat zudem wird die studie wie sie
natürlich selbst auffordert durch
weitere kontroll studien widerlegt in
füssen wurde dem studienleiter auch die
erbliche approbation entzogen aus
gründen auf gut deutsch es ist
kompletter quatsch
aber dieser quatsch hält sich zum teil
sogar in ärztekreisen und wenn jetzt
argumentiert wird dass es ja hier nur um
geldmacherei der pharmakonzerne geht
dann ist das auf kompletter hof die
pharmakonzerne können sich nicht mehr
alles oder nichts besseres als gegner
wünschen denn dadurch bleibt die
krankheit erhalten und der impfstoff
wird weiter benötigt die pocken zum
beispiel sind durch die weltweite
impfung ausgerottet worden ich wurde
noch eben jetzt wird nicht mehr gegen
pocken geimpft die pocken gibt es nicht
mehr
ein riesiger sieg für die medizin und
für die menschheit auch für die masern
strebt die weltgesundheitsorganisation
whu das an
doch impfgegner machen ja einen strich
durch die rechnung das ist zum einen
schlimm war das einfach menschen tötet
man kann eben tödlich sein und es zögert
den moment hinaus an dem die masern
ausgerottet worden sie in den belgien
sind jetzt knapp 300 menschen erkrankt
und das ist der grund für diese
reisewarnung und eine frau hat sogar ihr
kind verloren das ist doch einfach
furchtbar
dabei ist eine info etwas ganz harmloses
und natürliches es werden keine fremden
so tanzen verabreicht keine chemie nicht
unnatürlich ist lediglich abgeschwächten
viren werden initiiert deren wirkung ist
20-fach achtung 20-fach harmloser als
die einer echten erkrankung natürlich
kann es bei den reduzierten risiko auch
zu komplikationen kommen es gibt sie in
vreden aber die sind halt deutlich
geringer als bei einer erkrankung ich
verstehe ins gegner wirklich nicht
empfinden wie ihre kinder als experiment
ihre objekte masernpartys was ist das
für eine menschenverachtende idee lieben
ihre kinder nicht ich kann so etwas
brutales und menschenverachtender es
wirklich nicht verstehen und sie
gefährden damit auch andere dabei wie
bisher jeder mensch direkt vor seiner
nase fast 90 prozent
in deutschland sind gegen masern geimpft
und haben die alle autos muss haben die
alle impfschäden die klare und
unbestreitbare antwort ist nein wir sind
gesünder als jemals in der geschichte
der menschheit die einzigen die das zum
negativen hin beeinflussen sind eben die
impfgegner
ja danke schön damit mittelbar
weitergeht ob die in frage steigt oder
fällt und dies vor allem mit der masern
epidemie mir weitergeht dass hierbei
klicks zum science fiction da halte ich
euch auf dem laufenden einfach hier ein
abo aufs auge drücken und nicht
vergessen mir einen haupt die glocke
gegeben
für den unwahrscheinlichen fall dass six
um noch nicht abonniert habt hier gibt
es die besten videos von klicks und
science fiction ich hab die playlist
nochmal niegelnagelneue zusammenstellt
also viel spaß und wir sind da dran